what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers
live together under one roof players
stop being polite
and start getting real this is the
champion
i'm so excited to make a big difference
at buying
maybe this season we can beat barcelona
too
it took a bribery scandal to get harry
maguire on the front page
me all it took was a haircut i never
cheated on my italian citizenship test
are you reading that off of paper now
[Music]
well that's a bit odd everyone's been
curious about my incredible
man-management of christian police well
i kind of told them a lie as a form of
motivation
but no i'm definitely manipulating him
okay
okay i told christian if he played
really well
this season i could maybe get him a job
in the queen secret service
what why would you do this
beg your pardon forgot to knock being a
secret agent is totally awesome i get to
do one-liners
and climb around in the air vent plus
chelsea has so much money to burn
they bought me like all these cool new
gadgets
[Music]
all right everybody on the coast spot
take the mask off of me what did you do
with frank
oh that is you hey frank i
fear christian's taking the spy bit a
bit too far
if i'm to get him back on side i'll have
to call in the big guns
hello jose no sorry no time to talk
right now um
may i have zlatan's number please
yeah boy pulisic christian
pulisic huh
zlatan ibrahimovic
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god
zlatan i got your note about the secret
mission
should be cool be cool okay here is the
stupid backstory
someone is kidnapping footballers and
turning them into
human trophies oh my god
there he is grab him i've said too much
run
hey leave him alone we were in the
middle of a conversation
fresh meat how about a taste of this
hershey's chocolate
don't bother following us christian
you'll never find us at our evil lair
located on roman abramovich's yacht
which is the only boat in the harbor
100 meters that way dang it they got
away
gosh now i'll never find their evil lair
hmm where could it possibly be
the boat they're on the boat man i bet
they're on the boat
oh wow the zlatan statue they must have
fixed it
nose is a little small though no i've
been turned into a trophy you idiot
trophies don't talk
congratulations ding dong you found me
sergio ramos who else no seriously who
else would be the bad guy
i'm gonna stop you well you can either
stop me
or save your friends
please save us yes we are so scared
the choice is yours mr pulisic
my friends or sergio ramos
friends or sergio
ramos my friend you can do both just get
a move on
right hang in there chaps i'll get you
down
wait
gee thanks christian you saved us hasta
la vista baby
your majesty oh gosh save me mr punish
let the queen go sergio ramos
right all right going geez what's an
overreaction this guy
oh thank you agent 10 you really gave it
110
terrific a proper spy job but that must
have been
very stressful and overwhelming enough
to make you
never want to be a spy again are you
kidding i'm just getting started
come on give me another mission give me
another mission anything anything
i now realize my liar sent christian
down a dangerous path of self-delusion
well there's only one way to sort this
with an even bigger lie
all right one more mission i need you
to go undercover as a chelsea footballer
so deep undercover that you'll never
speak of being a spy
ever again ever got it
oh that is so smart i mean
i don't get it at all but it sounds
really smart
there must have been an easier way to do
this
last one the training's a rotten egg
hope there's no lasers in there
all right please don't worry
that's all behind me i'm just a regular
old football player guy
now splendid
good show agent pulisic you've made
britain proud
and frank doesn't suspect a thing and he
never will
[Music]
if you enjoyed this jolly good show
please make sure to like and subscribe
to vr football
cheerio